we've spent the past couple of weeks
working our way through the chris sims
top 40 quarterback countdown yesterday
we began
the final ten the top ten now look there
are a lot of great quarterbacks in the
nfl and somebody's got to be at the
bottom of the top ten you're still in
the top ten
drew brees at number 10 tom brady at
number nine i got no problem with breeze
at 10 shireen brady at nine for me
seems a little bit low i was looking at
the other names that are still out there
to be ranked from one through eight i
think i would have brady at number five
kurt warner would disagree both with
sims and me kurt warner the hall of fame
quarterback got uh got a little heated
yesterday on twitter accusing chris of
basically click bait by putting brady
and brees where they are and i'll tell
you this
i know sims well he doesn't do things
for clickbait he doesn't do things for
attention he does things and says things
because he believes them and he believes
right now tom brady belongs at number
nine relative to the other quarterbacks
in the nfl i believe he's wrong but i
believe that he genuinely believes it
sheree what are your thoughts on drew
brees at 10 and tom brady at number nine
i have no problem with drew brees at 10.
i might even have put him at 11 below
carson wentz i realize carson wentz
hasn't had the playoff success but i do
think he has a ton of upside and i'm we
all know that drew brees is at the end
of his career and didn't look good at
the end of last season
i would have put tom brady way higher
because this is a guy who was an mvp
just two years ago and if you want to
say patrick mahomes is better okay tom
brady beat patrick mahomes in the afc
championship game and so i i just i
don't know how you have tom brady as low
as what chris did i don't think it's
clickbait i know chris very well as well
and i think this is what he believes but
we can certainly disagree with him and i
think we both disagree with chris on
this one and i may even disagree with
you a little bit because i think he
should be in the top five
i said i put him at five i'd put him at
number five
um because some of the other guys still
to be unveiled cam newton matt ryan
deshawn watson i would put brady ahead
of each of those so if you leap frog
eight seven and six that puts you at
five that's where i put him i wouldn't
put him ahead of patrick mahomes i i i
possibly would put him ahead of ben
rothersberger which will put him up the
number four but uh mahomes rogers
uh maybe it's just maybe he's third
uh uh maybe he's third after mahomes and
rogers either way nine is way too low
but again it's not because chris is
trying to create buzz or make a living
off of tom brady's name he has a ton of
respect for brady and for what brady's
accomplished and he would put brady
currently at number nine in the nfl in
comparison to all of the quarterbacks
and sharing i look at it this way
remember last year they gave tom brady
that incentive package
five different factors one million each
and it was based upon what he had done
the prior year and all he had to do was
replicate what he did in 2017 and he
would have made the five million dollars
he made none of it because he was it was
all based on his performance relative to
other quarterbacks and he was not high
enough in any of the categories to earn
a single penny of those incentives
relative to other quarterbacks last year
brady wasn't as good as he's been he was
still brady but other quarterbacks
really pushed it to a higher level last
year and brady didn't follow suit
no and i tell you what you look at the
weapons that brady's had in his career
and he hasn't had some of these weapons
that these other quarterbacks have had
and i think that speaks to the greatness
of tom brady and there's so many ways we
could speak to the greatness of tom
brady
the greatest quarterback greatest player
in nfl history and he's still playing at
that high level despite not reaching
those numbers i think we all agree he
had a really good season in 2018 it
wasn't as good as 2017 but it was a
really good season i think everyone
expects him to have a really good season
in 2019 as well
now i've had a chance to think about a
little more i would put him ahead of
newton ryan
uh deshaun watson and ben rothersberger
that gets him to number five the
question is is he ahead of andrew luck
to get to four i think the three that
would go ahead of him would be aaron
rodgers patrick holmes and russell
wilson
can can we at least agree on that or
would you put him ahead of one of those
three i'd put him at three i'm putting
him in number three i got him at three
behind who behind who
rodgers and mahomes
wow oh russell wilson not in the top
three the highest paid player in nfl
history not even in the top three of all
quarterbacks now there's some click bait
even though again we're not doing it to
generate attention we're saying what we
actually believe and i believe we're out
of time for this hour when we return a
special friday pft live draft based upon
shereen williams helping us out in a
pinch we'll be back with more right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports